au cours des 50 dernières années la
population mondiale a doublé les quatre
jours nous sommes un million de plus sur
la planète
c'est la plus grande crise de l'histoire
de l'humanité le thème a inspiré à la
fédération sa décision de ne plus
autoriser qu'un seul enfant par famille
en premier devant la loi sur le quota
d'enfants et bâtir un monde meilleur
pour nos enfants et vous pour cacher sa
du brouillard vous avez pensé à des
prénoms fait fi lundi mardi mercredi
jeudi vendredi samedi dimanche à partir
de demain zèle et sortir chacune votre
tour le jour de la semaine correspondant
à votre prénom
tous les dimanches sera dimanche qui
sortira lundi sortira le lundi et ainsi
de suite
[Musique]
hors de ces murs
vous adopterez toute l'identité unique
de karen cette manne
[Musique]
non c'est loupé
karen cette manne auriez vous quelque
chose à déclarer
et non
et quoi que vous fassiez il
vous trouviez il ne faudra jamais dire à
personne que vous avez désert et qu'est
ce qu'elle fout si elle est blessée est
morte
et si la police l'a retrouvé avant qu'au
début la rabine
il faut faire quelque chose pour elle il
faut sortir on n'a pas le choix
[Musique]
faites attention aux jo vous prendriez
un risque en sous-estimant les cette
manne
[Musique]
m
ensemble
[Musique]
nos dirigeants
il me faut une équipe de secours
bonjour lightman rtf pillay bienvenue
dans le wyoming
ainsi corinne anbar c'est lui qui a
découvert le corps
je connaissais cette vie qu'est ce
qu'une ado frais dans le coin
je sais ce que disputera ce qu'est ce
que vous faites déjà je chasse les
prédateurs
alors que diriez vous de venir en
traquer un pour moi
chercher des indices et vous ne voyez
pas les signes
oh mon dieu
on devrait pas attendre les renforts ici
le padro fortune
j'ai eu de la chance
nora parler le pont ce que tu cherches
ici on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
[Musique]
350 vis cruciformes voilà ce que je vous
ai commandé et vous n'avez libre et 329
évidemment que je les ai comptés avec ce
mec ça met seul [ __ ] on va dans la
chambre parce que c'est ma chambre de
mes paroles je suis car tout ça existe
lui s'en vient et c'est notoire
[Musique]
avec un style a évolué pendant le lock
avocat je ne parle pas votre langue lieu
la rentrée de franchir à coups les
pitchouns et yann mécanique à votre
langue
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
un milliard un milliard d'indiens quant
à une personne ici qui va s'occuper avec
d autres amis s'appellent agitera là il
est venu voir ici son oncle mais je vous
laisse ce n'est pas possible c'est
impossible je l' ai amené jusqu'ici et
maintenant vous le gard et il faut dire
combien de temps va tu restes ici
tourner on ne vient pas plus
[Musique]
auto feu sacré ah ben non il est en
train de dessiner
on se lève tôt se couche la seule chose
que tu sais dire c'est non alors ça non
tu sais le dire à la face t'es con j'ai
vu le méfait j'aime ça
la chance a dit tu es tombé sur toi
j'aurais aimé avoir sa chance et
pourtant je parle le français mais
[Musique]
je suis premier wii en qualité dans
production thé 6e seillière quand même
c'est une verdure la déco n'est fait
huit cent mille cellules alors elle est
pleine ouais
ouais c'était quoi ça c'est la
boulangère avant que je vais me caser
avec elle aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui moi je m'en fous du look a tout
loupé que tu sois paysans aussi ça me
dérange pas ça dérange alors ça peut pas
être là la maladie belge taëf hd là il
en parle partout à la télé avec les
hémorragies du taux tout ça tu penses
qu'à la fh d'elle très bien tout de
suite tu veux faire tuer toutes mes
vaches là ça
[Musique]
ja
ça fait exactement et où sept verges la
bâche a fait passer l'été dans la salle
de traite
tu étais fou tu as tu une vache tu lui a
foutu le feu on peut finir en taule tous
les deux pour ça tu es au courant je
souris les vingt cinq autres moi je sais
rien faire d'autre
j'ai jamais rien fait d'autre
[Musique]
mais s'il y en a une autre n'ont pas
s'il en est une autre
bonjour voila lors notre passé mouillé
qu'est ce que vous voulez à cette
heure-là
j'ai aussi vous avez le champ de libre
antenne le sont toutes
où les jambes wade vous même à ça
m'évite de monter et la maison n'aime ni
les chèques ni le plastique que le
liquide car débarrassées mois merci je
trouve est propre
je déteste désordre vous se trouvent les
clés pas sur les portes je les porte
[Musique]
alors qu'henry a ainsi offert un bon
double y est ce que vous pouviez me
ranger les les chaises et les tables qui
sont sur la terrasse pour les purs sur
quelque chose savaient plus à plein
d'autres choses je n'en vois bien que
c'est pas vous connaître de 3000 euros
l faut pas que tu met le doigt dans
l'engrenage avec 1,6 non seulement
attrape tout mais vous avez réussi de
faire marcher de machines à café
saupoudrait vous un petit arbre aussi
j'essaie de vous écouter n'essayez pas
ne sauvez moi et mon établissement c'est
sans espoir
vous reprenez vos bagages de retard je
me disais beaucoup indiquent ils voient
que du jus d'abricot c'est louche
non ne voyez pas méchante ça ne va pas
du tout mais j'ai tremblé face à braaten
a fait pas tout plaquer pour qu'on me
fasse tourner en bourrique comme avant
c'est fini les chieuses cio un embout
savarin quand je le dis quelques des
branques dans ce village
[Musique]
tu te laisser marcher dessus aussi une
bonne à voile et temps en temps donc
sachez pas fier mais vous comprenez pas
qu'il faut que je parte
[Musique]
toujours si vous étiez un gangster
confrères mais je suis aussi son agent
chez son producteur suit son avocat ce
sont deux chauffeurs jeu son garde du
corps sa mère des trois merci c'est tout
pour moi c'était j'aimerais faire venir
une personne sur scène quelqu'un qui
compte beaucoup pour moi qui a qui me
donne confiance qui m'est aussi des gros
coup de pression des fois mais sans qui
ce spectacle n'aurait jamais existé
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai moi c'est lui
photo so much et man who
ok
ouais
rappaz a placé les nouveaux acheteurs
sera bien temps qu'elle va venir
s'installer ici j'ai à te promets que je
prends mal c'était un setter mâle
thibault construire
combien de plage déjà ici 6200 f10 comme
ça je pense pas de faire un sketch mais
c'est celui du téléphone portable voici
les gages maintenant comme ta gueule toi
ta gueule c'est très peu de meubles de
passagers s'est récemment dit l'ex
patron dit pas exprès je voudrais quand
même retrouvé une place pour m'offrir
toi ton envie parce que la famille saini
un jour ou l'autre ça crée des problèmes
je sais pas si c'est un mec qui me veut
vraiment du bien ou si c'est un type qui
cherche un père pas fait un bon match
c'est pas forcément un arbitre les
ennemis c'est pas elle les ennemis c'est
ce qu'on aime le plus
alors savoir à tous que j'ai pas cette
vie soit responsable à un moment donné
parce que les choses vite que beaucoup
parce que tu as réussi c'est grâce à moi
n'oublie pas ça
[Musique]
young la rencontre d'un garçon solitaire
et d'une petite sirène enquête d'amitié
tous deux réunis par la musique celle où
une sirène
j'hallucine
[Musique]
voilà pour être honnête je crois que si
jamais été amoureux de quelqu'un
[Musique]
mieux si rennes si vous fréquentez avec
ces créatures en valeur s'abattra sur
notre mail john holmes
[Musique]
la mer votée rapidement la ville risque
d'étranglement
[Musique]